Whoa.
Where'd you come from?
The future.
Time travel is real?
Yeah.
You have no idea.
But why did you time travel back to this moment
in time?
I'm just typing an email.
Cause I just saw the movie Looper with you.
You know that movie where they send people
back in time to kill people, and then Bruce
Willis and Joseph Gordon Levitt are--
Yeah, I kind of wanted to see that.
--the same person?
Yeah, don't see it.
Well, why not?
Because you're going to hate it.
It's not bad.
It's actually awesome.
But you're going to nitpick all the time travel
logic stuff.
Well, I do think it's interesting the movie
thinks one guy can be in one time twice and
not cause some kind of space-time continuum
issues.
Right.
Exactly.
That's just one of the things you're going
to find a problem with.
Like, at the end, he's trying to kill this
guy that becomes evil, but, you know, trying
to kill him is what makes him turn evil in
the first place.
That's impossible.
Yeah, I know.
That's my point.
You're going to nitpick all the time travel
logic--
So you've come back in time to warn me, to
stop me from seeing the movie.
Right.
Doesn't that create a paradox in and of itself?
How?
You know, like, if you're successful, and
I decide not to see the movie, you can't be
here.
You'd have to disappear.
I think I'd be willing to disappear if it
means I don't have to listen to you complain
about this movie forever.
Okay.
I won't see it then.
Thank you very--
He did disappear.
There's no paradox.
I'm gonna see it anyway.
Dude, what the f*ck?!